live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
i'm ken coleman ramsey personality host
of the ken coleman show on the ramsey
network joined by my colleague
dr john delony who is host of the dr
john dalone show a ramsey personality as
well
and we are here to take your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five it is a toll-free
number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
now of course you're familiar with the
ramsey show and talking money
uh but we're gonna talk about more than
money
we'll talk about dr john's expertise
mental and emotional health
uh we'll talk about your work situation
do you want to make some more money do
you want to switch jobs you have a toxic
work environment oh john and i will team
up on that
and so what we need to do is figure out
what you
need and then we work together to
give you some practical advice john good
to be with you as always you too man
and thank you for reminding me to even
turn my microphone on yeah yeah i was
looking over there because i thought at
any moment
you're gonna jump in and the mic's not
gonna be on but that's what we do for
each other it's
well here's what we do um they bring me
in who's a hack
and next to a professional radio guy and
it works out really well for everybody
we have fun
especially the listener and we love to
help people that's right so john and i
are going to team up so again we'll take
your normal money calls
but john and i really do enjoy taking on
the especially when we've got yucky work
stuff
that's cause i'll talk to you about the
tactical and some of the some of the hey
what's my zone my country but there's
all this other
mental and emotional junk there john
it's all and we like to team up on those
so it looks like we might have one of
those to get started let's go to mobile
alabama where ricky is on the line ricky
how can we help
hey man how y'all doing uh thank y'all
for taking my call you bet what's going
on with you
uh well i'm i'm having a little trouble
uh believing in myself jumping off into
a new career path
and uh i'm just i'm scared to take the
leap
i've um i work i work at a alabama power
plant uh-huh
and uh i work seven days straight and
i'm off seven days and
i've uh i recently acquired my life and
health
insurance license here in alabama and i
want to
i want to do that full-time i'm an
independent broker i have contracts with
all the major carriers and i want to do
that full-time
and i'm just i'm a little bit nervous
about going to a
strictly commission based income from my
steady income now makes total sense i'm
gonna have john jump in on on some of
that fear stuff because he really is an
expert but i do want to talk tactically
too this is this hey
ricky i was i'll tell you this about
fear this is about tactics brother you
you've you've walked through you've got
the license you've gotten the
connections these contracts you're
you're into the fear part now it's just
about tactics and math
yeah so so so ricky here's the deal um
it's a straight commission deal
are you going to be truly out on your
own under another broker is that what
that means so if you were to go into
this which i'm not going to tell you to
do to just drop everything
and go into this unless we've got the
financial wherewithal to do it but if
you did that it's just you and you're
out there beating the pavement in mobile
alabama
trying to get people to buy their
insurance through you is that how this
is going to be set up
yes sir okay great how much do you make
right now in your power
the alabama power job uh last year i
grossed
59 000. 59 000 do you have any debt
i have two two vehicles i owe less than
um less than nine thousand dollars on
together okay that's it all right and so
you're are you on the baby steps now so
you're in baby step two knocking those
two out
yes sir okay great and so you know baby
step three is we gotta get that
three to six months emergency fund in
place uh
so right now you are in a financial
situation where
you can't just take a leap you could
but i don't think it's wise for you to
go to a straight commission leap right
now
and that's what you're feeling correct
right
right and and the thing uh the way my
work schedule is
with working seven days at the plan and
then having seven full days off
i've been able to uh i've been able to
to work
both that's where we were going yeah
you're way ahead you're already ahead of
me but i wanted to walk you through
you're afraid of something you don't
need to be afraid of so here's my point
because you've got this great job that's
seven days on seven days off
you're building the insurance business
on the seven days that you're off
and you're not losing any progress on
the debt free snowball journey
and then the three months expenses or
six months expenses
there's actually nothing to be afraid of
this is perfect you actually have a
full-time job that allows you
a full week in between your week of
working
to actually pursue the dream job so
go after it you have nothing to lose so
you have nothing to be afraid of john
that's where i've taken him
so ricky here's the hard part i'm going
to tell you about a conversation i had
with my boss
this morning uh oh and it's it's
something that i'm terrible at
and that my guess is you're gonna have
to learn how to do hold on one second
james can we get somebody from hr in
here
we don't know where this is going we've
had it hey ricky here it is
you're gonna have to be patient oh okay
we can yeah that's good that's good
you're gonna have to be patient you're a
go-getter yep you are somebody who rocks
and rolls and gets it done you run a
power plant you're the man
you make good money you're crushing
through these things i bet you're a fun
guy to hang out with
and then you decided i'm gonna go be a
broker i'm gonna build this stuff up
and now you're going to have to do the
slog grindy
turtle versus the hair work of just
showing up
week after week you're going to be
exhausted from your seven days on
you have to get up and make those phone
calls get up and do those things you
have to email those people back and have
call after call after call where you
make no sale no sale or no sale
you just have to be patient that's it
all right and that sucks it's not fun
and it's a hundred percent part of this
deal but
ricky when you replace
the 59 000 so you've got that insurance
business up to where it's bringing in
your monthly equal to your 59 000
job right now then you can tell the
power job by felicia
right but until then you stay with us
and then there is zero risk financially
thus nothing for you to be afraid of the
monster that you think is under the bed
is not under the bed that's right so
that's how we do it
now to your point john it's gotta be
patient that's tough
cause what happens is he starts getting
those first couple insurance clients i'm
out of here
oh i love this he's like i don't wanna
go to the power plant for seven days
straight here's what's gonna happen
he's gonna land three new clients in one
week right and then tuesday of that
following week at the plant
he's going to get called in he's going
to get ringed out for not filling out a
tps report the right way poor harold the
jerk comes in and throws his lunch box
on the ground
spills coffee he's like this guy he's an
idiot he talks politics all the time i
can't deal with this one more day and
the answer is you can't you have to
you got to keep going because on the
other side of all that slog
he's working for himself your own boss
hey yeah
ricky three years from now
you're gonna be on vacation with your
family
at the beach come out of the ocean dry
off lay under the thing pick up your
phone
and go oh just made some money while i
was flopping around in the ocean
am i right yeah so so and i'm having
some fun with this folks but i want you
to get this
that's the vision you hold on to during
the slog that's right
i'm doing what i have to do so that i
can do what i want to do
that's right and again this applies with
marriage
i want to just pop back off with this
conversation well that's a true don't
be patient it's with getting in shape
yeah like i want to work
have a hard week of workouts and just
look in the mirror and be like what's up
yeah that's not how that works yeah we
go to the gym for an hour we go to the
bathroom we start looking at our
waistline
it's like what happened wait it's not it
didn't shrink you gotta
keep going yeah gotta keep going we do
that with our spiritual walk everything
is about showing up and showing up about
patience right about being patient
and then you're right three years from
now walking out of yeah
all right the beach three renewals
that's right it's gonna be a good
christmas mama
that's the my times hey it's worth it
stay with it keep the eye on the prize
don't move more ramsey show coming right
up
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show thrilled
to have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are here taking your calls triple
a 825
5225 is the number triple eight
eight two five five two two five i've
heard countless stories i know you have
too from people who've lost a loved one
and were totally shocked
when they reviewed the will your final
wishes
should not be a surprise people when you
leave your family in the dark you're
setting up for huge
problems down the road so make sure that
you talk to them about your end-of-life
plans
the how to talk about your legacy guide
by the way john
really good job on whoever wrote that
because if it said the how to talk about
your death guide
yeah not great nobody wants to download
legacy legacy is a much
kinder much nicer the how to talk about
your legacy guide will help you have the
right conversations before
and after making a will it's going to
teach you how to specifically plan your
conversations
get on the same page with your spouse
ask people to be your executor kids
guardian or
power of attorney and tell the rest of
the family what's in the will
now you can give your family peace of
mind because there won't be any
unpleasant surprises
after you're gone text the word legacy
to 33789 to get your free how to talk
about your legacy guide today again text
the word legacy
23789
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to
indianapolis indiana
where james joins us james how can we
help
yeah i was um i have a 401k that
i just has a little bit into it and we
have
probably about nine uh 7 900 left on our
consumer debt
my thought was to take that out and just
pay that off take it out early
and pay off my consumer debt and then
start with the rest of the baby steps
no you should not do that you're so
close man i know it's so tempting
yeah how much have you paid off uh
we've paid off let's see
five and then carry the one and
yeah i know about 15 000. yeah good job
what's your payoff date
um it's gonna be mid next year yeah
here's the deal
you've got to be patient you guys have
done so much that 7 900
could probably be paid off closer sooner
if you get really really creative on how
you could do that and i love the idea
this came from creativity right but we
always say no to this question we'll
always say no because you're going to
take a tax hit
on this when you pull that money out and
it's an unnecessary
tax hit that money is stay in your 401k
and grow
you guys can knock that 7 900 out
probably quicker than you think
and even if you can't you're still going
to get it you're so close don't make a
bad financial decision
okay to try to make a good one you end
up
borrowing from your future self yeah to
pay back something that your past self
did don't do that to yourself
right hey let me ask you this james if
you went berserker mode
and just swallowed every last little
indianapolis ego pride you had
could you go get a job delivering pizzas
or drive an uber and just
crush this thing and pay it off
could i yes yeah yeah
hey i want to tell you we talked to
thousands and millions of people who pay
off debt
i want you to know that you think you
know how good it's going to be on the
other side you don't
until you experience it and when you do
you'll go home
i should have got here faster dude you
are worth going berserker mode and
getting this thing done do it do it do
it don't shortcut it don't borrow from
yourself from your future self
just go get another job and get it done
absolutely thank you for the call james
matthew joins us next in orlando florida
matthew how can we help
hey guys thank you for taking my call
you bet what's going on
so i'm 22 years old about to graduate
from college debt free
i have a job lined up in a couple of
weeks where i'm going to be starting
i'm about to start baby step four and
i'm looking at getting a new
car um so i'm going to be getting a
signing bonus
from my upcoming job and between that
and my tax return
i feel like i'm going to be able to put
together a lot of money towards a car
how much i'm wondering is i'm looking at
about 10 000 towards a car
um and then i'm looking at
potentially even going up higher to
closer to 15
000 but reducing from six months to
three months expenses in my uh
purchasing fund
i was wondering if you guys thought that
would be an okay thing to do if i wanted
to knock it down
to three months or if i should keep it
at six months
well bottom line is if you look at what
we teach we say three
to six months so you know uh are you
breaking some
rule no i just wouldn't do it you've
worked so hard to get
six months expenses that's a really good
night's sleep and you got 10k
this is all this is all as soon as you
start the new job and you're graduating
college debt-free
so we're only talking about three four
months of just super disciplined young
single guy
saving up the extra five so the answer
is no i would not do that
matt my wife has driven a car that we
bought for ten thousand dollars for the
last four or five years i think with our
two kids in it the car i bought i really
went all in
and mine was 16. now listen
there's nothing wrong with buying nice
cars and one day i hope to
but i haven't felt good enough financial
position to just go blow a bunch of
money
on cars this is your first gig you need
to get
uh buy ten thousand dollar car man be
super happy with it and just be about
saving that money up ken
made what i think is the most underrated
component to your health ken just called
it out it's a good night's sleep
and you're gonna get into your new job
and you're going to think this is this
boss is terrible
i don't want to be here i fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and you will have nothing to worry about
you got six months emergency fund a ten
thousand dollar car is gonna get you
anything to go
your options will literally be limitless
because you didn't go overboard
now anything if you had twenty five
thousand bucks in cash and somebody who
should buy cars that bad no
it's not i'm just telling you my own
house we i don't think it's that big of
a deal right
i did do this i went and bought a big
new fancy truck car
a truck when i graduated college for my
first job that was the stupidest
dumbest because i had to have it ken i
want to be so cool
yeah didn't need it man yeah matthew get
a 10 000 car and ride out man call it
good
yeah yeah i mean you got a couple
options there you know you're gonna have
a really good job
do not touch the emergency fund that's
why we call it an emergency fund
and uh you do not have an emergency but
uh congratulations
uh let's not move over the fact that
this young man for whatever reason it's
incredible he's graduating college debt
free that makes him a
um unicorn yes and all by himself that's
right
and and i think that's right i think you
know this this delay this delayed
gratification
on things that you can make a good case
for are the toughest ones to deal with
like this because he can make a case
well i could still have a three-month
emergency fund and he laid it out for us
and and and that's what that's the kind
of stuff that that
kills your progress that's right and man
i feel like this is a common theme
already in this hour it's just about
being patient
right it's just about being patient and
patient and patient buy
buy the a car that's gonna get you to
and from you're 23 years old you have
nothing to prove to anybody
get where you need to go and then head
on back man yeah you know let's talk
about this for a second because
you've been talking about patience and
patience and get staying with it and i
will tell you in my
own journey so i'm just speaking for me
here
you can psychoanalyze me my friend the
greatest tension that i have faced in my
professional life
and then i'm starting to see it now as a
parent with teens
the greatest tension i deal with is
the tension between persistence and
patience i got to get up and do the
right thing in my work
i got to get up and pay my dues learn
how to do radio right learn how to write
books all the things that you and i do
professionally right
how do we help people better yeah we
always wanted to help more people
so you and i are we haven't arrived no
so we have to get up and persist
right but we got these big visions i
want the payoff
and i got to be patient so i got to get
up and do i got to get up and show up
right but i also got to wait yeah right
some of you spiritually waiting on the
lord in your prayer life
waiting to see that kid figure that out
you know it's all the things
i struggle so much there john i'm just
going to give you a second to
talk to me because i feel it with it
listen it could be for something you
desire or it could be something that you
need desperately
again we it's our it's the air and water
that we
swim in and breathe and drink it's so
hard it's our culture that says
you know what you deserve it right you
deserve it now yeah and so they try to
remove the tension
i'm gonna pull all attention away i'm
gonna make it to where you don't have to
think about buying it i'm just
just give me your number i'll do it
automatically i'm just going to send it
to your house
you don't need to think about it that's
right why would what kind of loser
thinks about their electric bill
i got it just give us give me the number
i'll i'll charge you whatever i think's
a fair rate yeah right and if you go
back generations before it was
i'm gonna buy things make decisions
based on its effect
seven generations from now what's it
right folks
slow down and this is the time here man
oh yeah we're preaching ourselves hey
look if you want something that really
matters
you're going to have to embrace the
tension between persistence
and patience hey i got something that
will relieve your attention
there's more of the ramsay show coming
up don't move
[Music]
[Music]
so
the ramsay show rolls on from our ramsay
solutions
headquarters in nashville so excited to
have you with us eight
triple eight excuse me eight two five
five two two five john
you and i both do shows i almost
instinctively went into the number
for the ken coleman show yeah james the
producer over there that's happened i
think the many times i posted i've done
it i linked i think twice
i think you need to do it like i do it
which is i don't have the other number
memorized yet oh just on the floor i
know
see the more you do it it's just like
sometimes the incompetence comes in
handy
it does see thank you james that's
really the story
played well played but it really is a
psychological thing
like you know it's just amazing like how
many times you say that number and i
finally caught myself that's the first
time now that i've stopped it's like hey
oh there it is it's triple eight eight
two five five
five two two five that's the number to
jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five underestimate
incompetence yeah never
it's true james bringing the heat he
does he beats me up all day long love
you john he has a low self-esteem i i
let it happen it's
part of my it's it's a gift that's a
thing that's so good
all right hey we're here for your calls
and we're excited to do it baltimore
maryland is where we go
and oh actually okay there it is
faith in washington d.c that's where
we're going
faith how can we help hi guys um thank
you
so much for taking my call i am calling
because
i delivered my dream job and parasites
hey faith um uh can you try to stand
still and hold that phone as close to
your mouth as possible we're having a
hard time hearing you
sure there she is i got offered my dream
job and i am terrified
what are you terrified of so
i'm coming from the non-private sector
and switching into finance and i've been
passionately
interested in finance since i was 16 but
have never
done professionally and so i'm just
worried that i won't pass my exams that
you know i'll you know study for
everything and then just ultimately just
fail
tell us about the last time you worked
really hard on something and you just
failed it miserably
oh boy um college did you fail out of
college
no i did not know i think that's your
non-profit did you feel out of that
have you just been i did you failed at
it
yeah i it was a long story but basically
i got fired from my last job and then
applied for my
dream job kind of on the flu but like
well i got fired so
i don't really have anything to lose
then i got it but did you get fired
for incompetence i got fired for a
mistake that i made that was kind of
dumb but not like grossly
terrible there you go so that's what's
shaking you here's the deal
faith you just got the job they already
gave you the job
so you're in and so now you're going to
work on getting trained and you have
always wanted to do this
your equal parts excited and equal parts
oh
i've got this doubt because it's new and
i know what that feels like
it was 2017 faith i just become a ramsay
personality
and i was in orlando florida with my
family and i got a call from jeremy
brelin who leads our personalities
and he said are you sitting down and i
said uh give me a second i sat down
on a park bench at a theme park
he said hey this is not a guarantee this
is going to happen
but it looks like that siriusxm is going
to do
a channel a ramsey network channel
and you're going to have a live show
leading into dave ramsey
monday through friday if this goes
through how does that feel
now faith i was instantly excited
andy peed his pants okay there you go i
was thinking more sick to my stomach
because then i was like wait
a second yes i'm excited i want to do
this i've always wanted to do it
but i hadn't done it on that level
before and faith
the day before i was as sick as i've
ever been in my life
about a job why because i'm where you
are right now i'd always wanted to do it
i built it up in my mind it was the
dream job it is the dream job by the way
but i hadn't done it and i was like what
if dave thinks my show
sucks what if i can't help anybody
they're going to fire me my kids are
going to starve we're going to be living
in a box under the bridge
and my mind went bananas
faith what's the worst possible thing
that would happen
if you fail that first exam something i
don't think you're going to do
tell us um i'll get an additional 30
days to try again
oh okay so faith are you going to fail
miserably in this dream job
[Music]
the answer to that question is no don't
self-sabotage yourself yeah
you're going to crush this and like
if you don't then you get 30 more days
and you're going to do it again
i mean yeah i think it's also just like
i'm putting a lot of pressure on myself
because my grandfather taught me
everything that i know about finance he
passed away
a couple of years ago and so i'm also
just like well if i fail
then like what then i dishonored my
girlfriend
you're not you're such a sweet sweet
sweet heart but i'm going to tell you
something your grandfather
you didn't disappoint him when he was
alive you're certainly not going to
dishonor him now
faith this is all you're just creating
all these reasons why
you may have stepped into the wrong
thing that's what you're trying to do
right now
because you're there and now you got to
take the test and so the fear of failure
while that
that fear is it's it's embodying in you
and it's very real
the reasons why you're fearful they
aren't legitimate we just walk through
them we put them on the witness stand
there's no evidence faith and we're
having some fun with you
but at the same time trying to shake you
out of this because you have created all
these
things that could happen if you simply
don't pass
a financial test i'd take that
fear and anxiety and i would channel
that towards studying my head off
here's another cool thing faith coming
from the um
the non-profit world into the profit
world it's going to be an adjustment
here so
i'll cut through the tape for you the
the for-profit world
hires people for one reason to make them
money they would not have hired you
if they didn't think you could make them
money don't let your employer have more
faith in you than you do
okay they think you're worthy of the
challenge they think that you're going
to make them money
that means you should believe them okay
you're gonna do a great job
and let me just again the reason i told
you and our listeners that story
is because i got to a point where i was
really nervous john before that first
day
i promise you more than i've ever been
nervous
and i got to the point where i said why
am i doing this and i started focusing
on where i wanted to go
why i wanted to do the show why i was
willing to suck yeah because you do when
you start oh
the first time is the worst time and i
said i'm going to focus on why i'm doing
this and this is the pain
right the root word of passion means to
suffer
i'm willing to suffer my own criticism
and suffer
through making those early mistakes and
not doing as good a job as i could have
done
to get to the opportunity to do it long
term and help as many people as possible
you must begin with the end in mind and
you can't be focusing on all the things
that could go wrong because guess what
some of them are gonna go wrong but most
of them that you're terrified of aren't
gonna actually materialize so let's go
to that all the way to the end here
she goes and tanks her exams okay and
i'm not just talking about faithful
anybody they have this dream i used to
deal with this with my students
i was put on earth to do one thing be a
singer
the cosmos has called me to be a singer
i'm here and then they sing and you're
like
nope they didn't yeah it for sure yeah
isn't that right you know what still
true
person's still a person of value sure
still got purpose and passion
there is going to be some extraordinary
things they can do yes whether locally
or small or on a big scale
doesn't matter your who faith is is not
wrapped up and whether she becomes a
finance person or not and we often take
our identity and our future and our this
and it's all going to come crashing down
my kids are going to be able to eat
and they put a pressure on this one to
take the test yeah take the test
hit the dude in the mouth you're already
in the ring swing hard swing hard train
for the fight you're already in it yeah
i can just tell you
somebody who got hired for that job
already has the profession the
proficiency
that's right the talent to actually do
it so if you're not a good test taker
there's aids and all kinds of
opportunities and people that will tutor
you
there's so much help yes just ask for
help it's a choice and a decision
and study like your life depends on it
you'll pass the test who cares if it's
an a plus
call us back when you get to when you
when you pass the test oh that'll be fun
yeah we'll cheer for you yeah all right
folks we're just getting started
what do you need to talk about dr john
and not dr
ken are on the desk this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show we're
coming to you from our
national studios at our ramsey solutions
world headquarters i
am ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john delony and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to baltimore
maryland where chase joins us on the
line chase how can we help
hi uh so i'm in high school i'm 16 years
old
i've played for monster just high school
and we're a national scene
in football and i play wide receiver and
i have a very good chance to go
to division one level and have a full
ride scholarship to college
but i just started a real estate
business and i make about anywhere
between five to 20k a month
whoa doing real estate and
my father did the business and he scaled
it up to a million dollar bills a year
and i know i can do that but i don't
i don't have the time and effort because
i only work about two days a week
so i want to see what you guys depending
on this whole situation should be
my opinion is based on your answers
young man
congratulations first of all on what
you've been able to do
hold on so you're working about eight
days a month and you're making twenty
thousand dollars five to twenty thousand
yeah i i work um mondays and one day two
days i don't go to school
and i work maybe three hours a day yeah
okay so chase
do you want to play division one
football
yeah since i was young and what's the
dream beyond that do you have a dream
for the nfl
yeah i've been for nfl and i have a
dream from real estate as well so yeah
but here's the deal
here's the deal you don't have to choose
between the two what if i told you you
could
you could pursue both dreams
that would be that would be the best
part okay now here's the catch
you cannot pursue both dreams
at the same pace that's the catch
do you understand what i mean by that
yeah sure you do
so here's the deal you're already way
ahead
of so many young people i mean you're in
the top like 0.2
of young people in the country as far as
just making income while being in high
school
you can continue to grow that business
your dad's got
great expertise as you have laid out you
can hire some really good people to
continue to grow that
but if your dream is to play division
one football you need to go for that
and if you want to take a shot if your
health stays and you got the prospects
and you get to the point where you're
uh you're an actual uh prospect
go for it because if the nfl doesn't
come calling
you've got not a fallback plan you've
got another dream
waiting on you so i i say you pursue
both but understand you're going to have
to be patient on the real estate thing
because you cannot grow it to the level
you want to grow it to until
you can go full time at it but both of
those dreams are
there you're running at both of those
just different paces john
yeah man if you have the opportunity to
go go play football man
i look at it as it can tell me if i'm
wrong here i look at it as
as a scale if you will you can't
get to be 27 and say man i'm really done
with this
real estate dream it's time for me to go
to college and play football
that does not happen very well you can't
flip it that way yeah you can
get through your sophomore year of
college and realize i don't like the
pressure of d1 football it's a lot
that's
a full-time job it's a life i don't like
it i'm going to roll out of here and go
sell houses
you can do that right so absolutely one
of those things you
have to do now or you're cashing it out
the other will continue to be with you
as long as you go
and so man i i say double down and
here's the thing
enjoy your life you're 16 man yeah
you're 16.
real estate's not going anywhere yeah
and chase here's the other thing
i think you trying to grow this thing
while being a full-time student athlete
i think is going to make you a better
business person for the day when you
actually
retire from sports whether that's in
college if an injury happens which could
happen
or you go it's not for me and i'm tired
of the two-a-days and you know all the
stuff
i i think if you grow this thing as a
part-timer
to the point that you already have it if
you can keep doing it it's gonna make
you
better because you figured out how to
grow it on a scaled
part-time basis and you you want to talk
about repeatable principles that you're
gonna be able to do
man i think you're in great shape so go
play football yeah and enjoy enjoy high
school go play football yeah see what
happens
absolutely triple eight eight two five
five two two five
is the number to jump in on the
conversation dr john deloney
is my colleague with me this hour i'm
ken coleman justin's up next in
chattanooga tennessee justin how can we
help
uh yeah so i was actually just hoping to
get some kind of career advice
all right what's the question uh
well right now i'm just a general
laborer basically
uh i mean i work in a factory but i want
to get into the tech industry
in some way form or fashion you know to
make more money and
to be more fulfilled and so i was just
wondering if you had any advice about
how i could go about doing that
because i don't know if i should go to
school because i'm 28
or if i should do something online or
how to do that okay
so what we first start with justin is
what is the type of tech work we want to
do we don't have to be exactly sure but
we want a ballpark idea
do you have a couple of ideas or one
clear winner in your mind when you think
of this is the tech
job that i would like to get into
well i do want to get into development
so like making
web uh websites phone apps video games
that stuff
okay so here's what you do so you're
clear so now we want to focus on what's
it take to get qualified and the general
assumption
which i know that you've got an open
mind is that well i got to go to
four-year school
no you do not not to be a developer
and so what you've got to do is you got
to go a little deeper than my
general knowledge but to be a developer
there are uh
certain skills and then there are
certain certifications and things like
that that you need are you aware of that
i am i'm just not sure i mean there's so
many out there i'm not sure which ones
would be
good ones to get and then they all
they're all expensive so i just don't
know which ones to focus on
okay so what you need to do is i love
this and what you want to do is just
start to talk to developers
in chattanooga chattanooga tennessee do
you know anybody who's actually a
developer
i i do not and i've been trying to find
someone to talk to i just also don't
know how to go about actually finding
those people well i'm telling you
so what you need to do is you personally
have just said i don't know anybody
that's a developer so what you need to
do is
you think of all of your friends and
family in the chattanooga area
then you start thinking of all the
acquaintances you have including
co-workers
and you talk to everybody you come in
contact with
you know what maybe the butcher that you
get your meat from hey
you know anybody that's a developer
because this is what the process is
right you don't start with the butcher
john but i was making the point
you're gonna get to the book you're
gonna find a developer right and then
you say hey
would you make a connection for us and
just say look uh my guy
justin here he just wants to pick your
brain uh wants to be a developer and
wants to get your insight knowledge most
people are gonna be willing to do that
because they feel valuable by doing that
and so that's the beginning of what i
wrote in the book the proximity
principle which says in order to do what
justin wants to do
he's got to be around people that are
doing it developers he's got to be in
places where development is happening so
even if you know somebody
justin who works in a company that
employs developers
call that person they're your good
friend and they and then say hey
would you ask them if i could shadow
them for a day now justin do you know
anybody
that works in a company that has
employees that are developers
uh not to my knowledge the answer is yes
you do yes you do
you just haven't started this process so
don't make this so difficult
literally you're talking to everybody
that that you know now here's one other
thing i want you to do
i want you to go to betheltech.net they
are a partner of the ken coleman show
they are training people in a nine-month
period
online you don't have to go anywhere you
can do it at home
and ramsey solutions listeners they get
a discount because they're paying cash
you can cash flow your way through this
they have a nine month program it's less
than fifteen thousand dollars and they
can get you qualified they place you
uh making seventy five thousand 000 just
getting started within a couple years as
developer you're gonna make six figures
that's just one option i'm not telling
you they're the only option
but there are other organizations like
that go do your homework
all you got to do is search and those
type of options like bethel tech it's
betheltech.net
ken if you want to just talk to them do
your homework talk to them are they the
right fit or is there another
school like that that will do this all
online pay as you go
and they're going to get you equipped
they can tell you what you need as well
so talk to real developers
get their take get three or four of them
those opinions like in a bucket
talk to betheltech talk to other
organizations locally there's probably
some in tennessee john
just do your homework ask lots of
questions and just like we tell people
for our smart investor pros
go with the one that feels right the
best fit and justin you
can get there and you will start today
all right great hour john always fun and
also with you thank you sir
to our producer james childs our
associate producer and call screener
kelly dean thank you all very much but
mostly thank you folks
for listening this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john delony
we are ramsey personalities and we host
shows of our very same name
and we are here together to serve you
this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five john tell them what calls you
specialize in
tell them now what is it you gotta have
your mic
there it is relationships mental health
all of it there it is
education what's going on in your hearts
and your minds and your families and
your workplace and your
communities all of it all right and then
i specialize in
hey what were you born to do is work
just a job
that's designed to give you what money
you need to live or
are you created to contribute in your
work is there a purpose i think you were
created to fill a unique role in your
work that means you are needed
and it means you must do it somebody
needs you to show up so how do you make
the transition how do you discover what
that work is or if you know what it is
you don't know how to get there how do
you get there or
uh oh what if you're on the path john
and you're not getting promoted as fast
as you like so
those are the type of things we talk
about and of course we're gonna talk
about your money
so there you go open phones triple eight
eight two five
five two two five is the number dallas
texas is where we go next
chase joins us there chase how can we
help
hey so i just got a new job
um i'm getting paid double what i'm
going to be
uh what i was getting paid hey
congratulations
that's awesome so um it comes with a
relocation
after some math um my emergency fund
looks a bit excessive um it's
i'm moving into a lower overall cost of
living area significantly lower
and my six months of expenses that i've
got saved up now is looking more like
10.
if i move to um wow to where i'm moving
so
do i just save that as a instead of
rainy day fund a nuclear fallout fund do
i
move that around i won't be eligible to
uh
put into a 401k until
uh 90 days into my employment so i
haven't quite reached that yet
um and my roth is already maxed my roth
ira is already maxed out for the year
are you going to buy a house are you
going to rent
uh right now we're renting okay do you
have any intention because that's
my first thought is roll that into a
down payment fund for a house
yeah right you know we aren't really
looking for sure to
um to settle down into a house yet
because i'm
my goal is actually to relocate uh with
this company after putting in a few
years
and but but but still you're not maybe
you want a house
well i'm with john on this i mean
there's there i think there's two ways
to go
i think i'm with john that because you
guys are a young couple and you're
making some great progress you're in
wonderful financial
shape i'd put that in a nice you know
put it in my market account
nice money market account and sit on it
until you guys get clear with what you'd
want to do the other option is you
certainly could invest that
uh with our gross stock mutual fund
strategy and things like that and
let that money start working for you but
again let's say that two years from now
you keep moving up the ladder
and you move and now you're ready to buy
and that money we'd never tell you to
pull that out now that you've invested
that money and it's doing good for you
but
it's prolonging that down payment on a
home i like parking it in the uh
uh in the fun and where you where you
can make a little bit so
you know you're not going to get a huge
return on it right now but
it gives you options i just wouldn't let
it burn a hole in your pocket
right all right thank you yes okay
that's good
yeah i think i think we're good there i
think he's only got a couple options
there you know i hate to see him not
have that money available when he's
ready to buy a house
yeah ken why is it so hard to stay on a
plane
you know what i mean uh yeah that's a
that's a deep question i
it's just it's like you follow it you
follow it you follow it you know what i
should be doing to something else
well i'll tell you what i think is going
on with him okay he's going
i should be making progress with this
money ah okay
i don't need it for my it's too much for
my emergency fund
is it really i mean because here's what
i hate about my emergency fund
using it oh man yeah you know that's
true well yeah absolutely
as soon as you have to dip into it i
never feel
i am grateful for it but i always go oh
geez i want to get dead i got to fill
that back up so is it really that bad to
have a
couple of extra months or four months in
his case no but i think it's the mindset
of progress we humans we're like oh i
got this extra money
if i just put it savings i'm just
wasting it setting it on fire
yeah right instead of working towards
something i think that's it don't you
i mean that's the only thing i can think
of other than i i just know i can get
two months into a really great workout
program see some
really great progress and i start
getting bored
yeah and then i think you know what i
probably should be doing something else
and then i look up two months later
i'm completely derailed doing something
nonsensical in there yeah i think this
guy's on top of things and he's just
falling into the progress trap
that's a good question that's a good
playful question yeah yeah
triple eight eight two five five two two
five norfolk virginia is where we go now
adriana is on the line how can we help
hi it's honored to talk to you all so my
question is
that i've been i'm in college and i've
managed to save a thousand dollars and
i'm wondering
would it be better for me to put that
money into an s p 500 growth eps in my
roth ira
or into my business how much money did
you say
a thousand dollars a thousand what's
your side business
so my side of the business is called the
parental craze it's a body care business
where i just make products like lotions
and
organic natural products like that and
it brings in about 50 to 60 a week so
like 3 000 a year
and i just want to keep growing my
business okay so
yeah i i wouldn't put a thousand dollars
in the stock market i would just open
a business account a checking savings
account and leave it there
yeah give yourself that cushion in that
side business you don't want to lock it
up in the stock market with just a
thousand dollars that's going to be what
you reinvest in your company that's
going to be your emergency fund for your
company
that's going to be your scaling money
for your company so that's us that's
you're you're well in your way you're
planting seeds for a future company
there but yeah i wouldn't overthink that
money
yeah absolutely thank you for the call
uh let's see thomas
is up in salt lake city utah thomas how
can we help
yeah so i'm just trying to um get back
into
financial stability um i was out of work
for a while due to
a medical issue and separate depression
and
just totally ruin uh overdrew bank
accounts and stick out loans and
just trying to see like there's life at
the end of the tunnel
yeah well there absolutely is give us a
snapshot of what your financial
situation is
um right now i probably owe around
uh i took like two loans at work
probably like
2 800.
i have a um payment and my rent's really
next to nothing because i live with a
good friend how much do you owe on your
car
um just over
8 000 so you have you have 2 800
in loans you have 8 000 in a car what
other debt
uh student loans how much
um probably 18. okay all right thomas
here's what we're gonna do
that music means we're coming up on a
network break but good news for you
i got you on hold when we come back
we're going to get the full picture
of what your debt situation is we've got
the plan the baby steps work for you
we'll walk you through that we're going
to help you out don't go anywhere
john's gonna talk to you a little bit
about some of that emotional stuff that
you might be carrying
as well thank you thomas for the call
thank you for your patience folks don't
move we're gonna help thomas and you
on the other side of the break this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from nashville
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney
as we went into our last break thomas
had joined us
and thomas has been through some stuff
john we haven't heard the whole story
yet we're going to get to it but
as a result of some of the stuff he's
been through he's in a tough financial
spot
so we're getting a sense of where he is
and so
we bring thomas back on here so we can
dive in all right thomas
uh so i want to make sure i have the
full debt picture
2800 in some loans 8 000
uh on the car in 18 000 in student loan
debt is there any other debt that you
have
um let's just put it up to like with the
loans probably like
34 just in case okay 34
everything included yeah okay and then
other debt um not that i could think of
a top of my head right now now
so i'm a little nervous about the fact
that off the top of your head you can't
think of any other debt that you might
have so um i we want to know that this
is your financial picture and then are
you
in a uh are you an employee are you
employed right now or are you in between
jobs what's going on there
employed a full-time job plus i just
took a little
part-time every other week like 12 hours
being a doorman for a bar
how much are you making in the full-time
job
um just over
22. okay and how much you bringing in on
the part-time job
11 an hour or 12 so let's say 12 hours
every two weeks
okay all right john you were going to
jump in
yeah so i want to back up a little bit
man why'd you
what was the medical issue are you in
the hospital uh
blood clots in my leg and then i was out
of work for about
i don't know two months and yeah got
really depressed
okay and so you had some medical issues
that pulled you out of work
tell me about this depression
i'm not really one that he's sitting
around all the time okay and i was
sitting in my house because i couldn't
work and i'm one class and
i was also because the depression uh
decided that drinking would
solve the discretion which made it worse
and what what what kind of rattled your
cage a little bit to get you
back out of the house and get a job did
you get a clean bill of health
yeah i uh my doctor finally allowed me
to go back to work and
then um i was drinking a lot in overdrew
bank accounts
of my bank account and decided i just
need to stop so yeah do you have an
alcohol problem
uh i don't think so i just think i was
self-medicating when i knew i shouldn't
have been
is being a doorman at a bar the smartest
position for you right now
um i don't know to be honest i haven't
thought about that
yeah it's probably not okay
what is it about you that thinks you're
worth 22 thousand dollars a year
um i will really i just was trying to
get out of this financial situation so
i was ready to take anything to help
bring in a little bit extra money
what do you want to do thomas what have
you dreamed about
man i want to travel um i'm on like my
my
my bucket list main bucket list is to
see every uh major league
game and every fall part all right
appreciate that dream what are you
dreamed about
doing what kind of work do you think
about you know if i'm doing this kind of
work
and i'm making this kind of contribution
through my work i'm a happy man
it's my perm well it's my full-time job
is is i i work for a great company
and i don't see myself ever living in
this place what are you doing
i still don't know what you do um oh i'm
a cable
technician okay and so you love working
with your hands and solving problems
with your head and hands
yes okay so if you want to stay with
that company do you see a ladder
at that company where you keep moving up
have you looked ahead definitely
okay good they're going to pay more than
22 000 a year
yes okay so i'm going to jump on
something that john said he's right you
need to get you need to quit the
bar job today you don't need to be
hanging out in a bar when you've just
come through some really tough
battles with alcohol what you need to do
is get a side job fixing stuff
because that's what you're good at you
use your head and your hands to solve
problems
and in this economy in the trades you
can make some really good side money and
i i love that you said you've identified
this company as a ladder for you
so that's great but you need to get out
of that unhealthy environment it's just
not a good place for you make some more
money
uh so that you can get out of debt and
you need to get gazelle intense are you
single
uh or you got a relationship what's
going on there
bingo how old are you
38 38 okay so you're only making 22 000
you need to be you need to be working
yourself well hold on hold on when you
asked how much i made i was pointing i
was talking about 22 an hour
um oh okay okay okay i went with john
so what are you making oh i apologize
yes yes
22 just over 22 an hour i apologize like
48 a year
okay oh okay that helps me sleep a
little better all right so here's how we
get financially
here's how you get financially stable
you're gonna walk the baby steps out
have you heard us talk about the baby
steps
i have i need to get the book to really
realize what they are we're going to
give it to you
all right i'm going to send it to you
for free we're going to send you the
book for free
total money makeover we're also going to
give you a free trial to ramsey plus
which will come with uh there are
budgeting world-class budgeting app
every dollar so that you're not going uh
uh like you have been on most of the
questions you actually know where your
money is and you learn how to budget
there's some other great tools in there
as well okay so we're going to give you
ramsey plus
a free trial we're going to give you the
book total money makeover but here's
what you do
baby step one is you need to put a
thousand dollars in a
savings account and that is your first
emergency fund
a thousand dollars baby step two is we
begin to attack your debt
and we call it the debt snowball and
that is the smallest debt
you attack that first if you've got a
minimum payment of a couple hundred
bucks on one of those loans or whatever
you're attacking everything you've got
extra beans and rice
you are working another job that's not
in a bar making as much money as
possible and you are attacking
that smallest debt once you eliminate
that smallest debt
you take the minimum payment that you
were putting into that plus everything
else you were throwing at it
and you roll it into the next thing are
you tracking with me thomas
yes yes you can have this 34 000 paid
off
for 18 months how much is your car worth
oh um 3 000. all right so you don't have
much there so you got to knock down so
here's the deal
you are working hard you're working so
hard you don't have time to take a drink
yeah you're getting off of work and
you're
you're going straight into delivering
for uber or whatever uber eats and
you're hitting the road until late at
night you're getting up and you're doing
it again to get this debt paid off okay
okay but yeah listen i'll just say this
thomas please go get a trade job
well you can fix stuff with your hands
you know enough guys in the business
you're in that's where you'll make the
most hourly money
go do something you're really good at
and keep getting a skill while you're
doing it do you understand what i'm
saying don't work in a bar
yes get good while you're getting out of
debt
and here's the beautiful thing about
healing from depression it's little
winds
and little winds and little winds little
steps and little steps
okay and you said it best
we're not made to sit at home and it's
frustrating and it was it was exhausting
for you
and the thing that sucks about alcohol
is it helps it works for a season
and then it kills you right it takes
everything from you and you experience
that firsthand
so i want you to look at going back to
work
hard getting that second job ken was
talking about getting a third job on the
weekends after that
i want you to look at those little
little steps little steps you're going
to look up in 18 months i want this
thirty four thousand dollars gone
i want it gone so hang on the line here
we're gonna give you a copy of total
money makeover we're gonna get you
signed up for ramsey plus
and we want you to follow this through
and i want you to call us back in a year
when this debt's almost gone or 18
months when it's totally gone
and we're gonna cheer with you yeah
little steps little steps you can do
this brother
we got faith in you thomas listen to me
thank you
listen to me what has happened to you
and what you did
is not who you are it does not define
you
use this as a refiner's fire and you've
been in the fire and then like the
blacksmith puts that
wrought iron into the fire and lets it
get crazy hot then he pulls it out
what's he doing then
and he shapes it let this thomas shape
you
and your best days are ahead young man
don't you get down
i understand why you did but believe
that you've got a unique contribution to
make and i think you've seen the latter
and that's exciting get focused get your
eyes on the prize and do not
quit there is light at the end of
every tunnel that's true good stuff
all right i'm looking to my left out in
the lobby
of ramsay solutions and i see a very
excited young couple
and they're gonna do a debt-free scream
it's our favorite part of the show and
it's coming up next don't move this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony
it is a free call to jump in on the
conversation triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five and in
the lobby of ramsey solutions
oh it's a fantastic young couple
standing on the stage
christian and lauren are with us
christian lauren hello
hey hi guys how you guys feeling right
now pretty good
[Laughter]
where are you from we're from i'm
originally from oklahoma but uh we live
in austin texas right now austin texas
all right
okay so how much debt have you paid off
we paid off 62 000 in 18 months whoa wow
all right and uh what was the range of
income we started at a 114 000 and ended
up with about 150
by the end whoa tell me about that rise
in income
well it's it's working a lot of nights
uh staying up late
arguing with each other late at night
while we're working um but a lot of a
lot of side work what do you guys do for
a living
uh i work in product marketing at a tech
company and
and then i also do social media
marketing at a tech company as well okay
same company or different companies
different different yeah yep what was
the late night arguing about i mean
i think social media probably probably
social media
yeah not going to bed together that's
always annoying yeah we took on some
side projects so i think it was just
hard sometimes working the late nights
having different nights we work late and
we started paying off debt right as we
got married um about two years ago so
it was jumping straight into it yeah
we're figuring out how to be married
anyway much less absolutely working like
crazy yeah
wow so what was the debt
it was uh about a 50 50 split about 29
000
in a truck that i decided that we needed
as soon as we graduated and got married
of course
and then about 30 low 30s in uh
student loans okay all right oh boy and
so what was the
what was the impetus to do this here you
are this young couple and what what was
it
and when did it happen well it took a
little while i think it took us about
six months to get on the same page
i grew up super i was i took a lot of
debt out i
took a student or a loan on a car when i
was 16.
super used to that she had never had
that before um we knew we wanted to
change our family tree
so we got on the same page and just uh
went after it
how did you come in contact with ramsey
solutions in this this financial piece
and baby steps how'd that come to you
the podcast listen to the podcast we had
a bunch of eight hour road trips up to
oklahoma and i
uh subjected lauren to a lot of pain on
those drives
how painful was it well i think for me
it was a little bit harder to get on
board just because
i've never i think coming to the idea of
us having to pay off this massive amount
of debt so early in our marriage
i was a little bit angry about that and
so i remember he would play these
podcasts and be like
turn them off and then i remember one
trip i finally was like
okay we're gonna do this and then six
months into our marriage we started
really
committing to the plan and like actually
moving forward with it together
who told who the trucks got to be sold
we didn't sell it
oh yeah yeah we did tell each other many
times and we should sell it
um but we did decide to keep it yeah i
kept it
wow so what do you tell young couples or
anybody quite frankly who's
early on in this journey they've decided
they're going to do it
but they're mad like you were lauren i
don't want to do this don't make me do
it
what do you say to him i would say
commit to it
it's so so worth it early on in your
marriage
and it really does help you become a
team together which is so important in
marriage and
even though a lot of people would be
angry about it being so early
in marriage it really right off the bat
just starts you on a good foot
so when you when you see you keep
mentioning early in marriage yeah are
you talking about this idea that when
you're
newlywed everything should just be roses
and beachfronts and like
swimming in lake travis just running
around being like instead of
working all day and then working all
night and saturday and sunday
yeah i think there's this whole idea
that your first few years of marriage
need to be this
beautiful bliss and so easy and i think
that was the hardest part for us was
a bunch of our friends who got newly
married were buying houses
and they were really like starting this
beautiful life well we were in a 700
still are in a 700 square foot apartment
together
both working from home and so i think
the comparison was really hard
in the beginning for us and now you
understand that that lifestyle that your
friends that are getting married
is a mirage yeah it's a charade right
yes and you're gonna walk out of this
700 square foot apartment
with this strapping young man next to
you with the filson hat
and y'all are gonna go walk straight
into a debt-free
next rest of your life right so this
stuff that when you finally achieve
those things
it's gonna be real it's gonna build be
built on a strong relational foundation
financial foundation
and it's got long-term life-changing
stuff right yeah absolutely yeah
now we know you guys by this rise in
income and you've already told us you
guys worked like crazy
which is great what are some of the
sacrifices or what's one of the wackiest
thing to your friends or family maybe
that you guys did to either cut expenses
or pay something off faster
well no i would say one for us lauren
loves to travel
absolutely no vacations we went to
puerto rico for our honeymoon and this
is our first vacation
in about two years yeah so this is very
similar to puerto rico here
yeah well played yeah that's awesome uh
so
was there a point in this journey um
in the 18 months where it clicked where
we went from
struggle and just striving to oh
this is we feel some momentum here i'm
just curious
yeah i think for me it was about three
months in lauren
and i finally got on the same page and
we went from paying that 500
a month car payment to getting after it
putting thousands and thousands a month
towards debt
and we just got pretty pissed off to be
honest and
that's when it clicked and we decided if
we're going to do it let's do it and
let's do it quick
what did it feel like to get that truck
title in the mail amazing
yeah it's all mine there's millions of
people who have never felt that
and there's something about getting that
truck title that's just like ah it's
mine
right right and it's also awesome when
she's not mad at you anymore for making
such a terrible chance
isn't that true yeah you touched on this
earlier i just want to ask this really
quick i want you to speak to couples
you can both jump in on this if you want
uh yes you're a young married couple but
you're just a married couple forget the
amount of time
when you jumped on together on this
journey and you really locked arms and
got going together and now you're on the
other side of this about ready to do
your screen what is it done for your
marriage and your relationship
i think personally on my end it's just
taken so much pressure
off of each other and um
we both have a lot of dreams that we
want to pursue in the future and so
i think it just allows us that extra
freedom to be able to go do that
i think for me the the biggest part of
the journey in our marriage was just the
unity that it brought
between us just to have to work together
towards a common goal
um it was just awesome struggle
ends up in connection man that's so
great i'm excited for y'all
congratulations for setting a model for
couples who've been married for 50 years
or couples who've been married for two
months couples who are thinking about it
good for you guys
you're on the stage now the finish line
is right before you guys ready to do
this let's do it
all right here we go folks it is
christian and lauren from austin texas
they paid off 62 and 18 months going
from
114k to 152k
count it down let's hear your debt free
screen
three two one we're debt-free
there it is they did it
look at that look at that gaze isn't
that fun
the married couple the young married
couple they haven't been on a vacation
since the honeymoon but worse they went
to oklahoma a few times
that's the opposite of a vacation oh man
the texas boy taking a shot
across the red river there kelly daniel
at texan uh is very excited she's got
like touchdown hands
in the control room yeah hey they put
the time in and here's what they did
know they were doing they knew they were
getting out of debt but they didn't know
they were investing in this struggle
yeah and struggle when you struggle
together
it works with our military it works with
sports teams it works with
with businesses works in relationships
when you struggle together for a common
purpose
man it builds connection it builds the
strength it makes that
that connect connective tissue so strong
so
tight good for them i'm so excited for
them yeah it's really true coming out on
the other side of the storm
i it just makes that sun warmer
brighter i wish i could see how big
they're smiling oh
literally they're lighting up the studio
in here for you podcast listeners yeah
it's awesome
why by the way you need to check it out
on youtube my goodness gracious stakes
alive to watch that
it's uh it's invigorating so
[Music]
we gotta go say hi and congratulate him
high five but don't move
more of the ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
nashville
ramsay solutions studio so excited to
have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are taking your questions about
life
relationships work money just general
progress
we want to equip you and encourage you
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
are you tired of feeling stuck with your
money like you're never gonna get out of
debt or save enough for the future
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make progress with your money and faster
than you think
but you've got to have a budget that's
why you need a ramsey plus
membership you're going to get access in
ramsey plus to the premium version of
our every dollar budgeting app where
you'll plan out every dollar you spend
and save
before the month begins you'll connect
your budget to your bank
so you never miss a transaction and
you're going to get custom budget
reports that show you
where you can find more money to put to
your towards your goals when you budget
and get intentional with your money
you will make progress and quickly you
can start budgeting for free today
start your free trial of ramsey plus by
texting the word
trial to 33789 that's trial
two three three a hey kim before we move
on
um you've got a massive cool big event
coming up
can you tell us about it oh yeah thank
you very much uh it's coming up
tuesday april the 27th it's entitled
get hired and basically what we're doing
is a deep dive into how you beat the
competition you think about how
competitive the job market is now
and quite frankly even when you know you
have a lower unemployment rate
when you're when you're interviewing for
a job or you're trying to find the right
job it's
a process and so we're going to detail
the process out
what you need to be doing and then how
to do it it's called get hired
tuesday april the 27th live stream event
it's only 20
all you got to do is text the word hired
to 33789 text the word hired
to 33789 and uh like i said 20 bucks
john
could be a great gift for a college kid
who's trying to figure out how to
navigate this world or just somebody
who's down
feeling like hey i've i've applied i've
applied i've applied i've done
interviews i can't get hired
yes you can we're going to show you how
so thanks for bringing that up but yeah
it's going to be a fun live stream event
tuesday april 27th
8 eastern 7 central uh
get hired and i want to make sure
everybody knows
over the last year all these different
companies have thrown up all these
different kinds of live streaming events
which are basically glorified zoom
meetings
this is not our team is so world-class
dude they wish you and
right you've got a group of absolute
world-class
professionals back there and it will be
a production it'll be a show it'd be
worth sitting down and watching yeah
and get some great clarity watch some
live things i'm excited for it
thank you brother we want to help you
get ahead so check it out all right to
the phones
we go atlanta georgia is where we're
going to pick up bill
bill how can we help yes sir i
appreciate y'all taking my call
uh y'all doing all right gentlemen oh we
are really having a blast what's going
on
good uh forgive me i'm gonna be a little
bit nervous about this but oh you're
doing great
i am 62 years old i am a truck driver
uh i am on baby step number four
i'm thinking about going back to online
school
for i.t an i.t profession
uh it's just getting i i do enjoy my job
but it's just getting physically harder
on me every day and so i never plan
on actually retiring just maybe cutting
back on my
hours so i thought maybe getting into
the i.t
field would be something that would
come up maybe years from now that i
could get into where i could quit
driving a truck and start doing that
the community college in my area offers
some certificate programs at i.t
of different subjects and i was
wondering if
y'all thought that would be the best way
to go
well i think it's a really good way to
go i think you get to determine if it's
the best way to go
in the sense of is technology what you
really want to do in these later seasons
it certainly gives you that flexibility
and it's something that you can begin
doing pretty quickly
you know once you get that certification
and you can begin to to get
opportunities to do it even while you're
in the truck you know some freelance
type work i think it gives you a lot of
versatility
but what makes this is this the best
move
uh is this if this is what you really
want to do i will tell you that you
don't have to have a ton of technical
experience
to get technically qualified to be able
to do work like technology i mean i work
with a great organization that's
training people
in nine months so you know that's the
issue if this is something you really
want to do
yeah i think you should do it and i
think you should do it as cheaply as
possible you don't need a four-year
degree
that's not something you're entertaining
anyway so it's where who can train me
to do what i want to do so the question
is do you know what type of technology
work you want to do
no sir not yeah the different subjects
one of the first one i'm looking to is
just the i.t
fundamentals uh to get into the
uh beginning stages of it and then
probably progress from there
i don't think i'd ever be good at being
a programmer or something like that but
actually a uh a help desk specialist
right or somebody that works on
computers
or something like that would be
something that i would think i would
really enjoy
okay great so bill here's where we start
so you're 63 you've got a lot of
relationships you know even more people
than you think you know
and so what you've got to do is you've
got this idea i think i would like to do
some just
basic you know computer maintenance
fixes
it help you need to start to connect
with
over the phone over lunch or coffee
with somebody who's in that actual job
and the reason you do this
this is the equivalent of the old days
when you were in school
and you would do some type of a term
paper or some type of a report where you
would research something
and so we want to do is we want to
clarify and verify you've got an idea we
want to clarify everything that's
involved in that
on a day-to-day basis what are you doing
what do these folks like about it the
most what do they like the least
and then you want to look into all right
uh what's it going to take to get
qualified to get into that
and so that's the clarify and verify
when you look into all those answers
your heart's going to either go ding
ding ding
or the big red family feud x and so bill
that's all you've got to do
so that's what i want you to do i want
you to really start hanging out with
or try to talk to people that are doing
that type of it work
and it's going to verify it for you
okay that sounds good i appreciate it
hey bill i want to tell you
one more thing you have just
this is this this has been a a long day
here
we've been working since early this
morning i want you to know that
you have absolutely put some wind in my
sails and you have called
everyone in america's bluff who says
this is just what i do i've been doing
this too long to
to fill in the blank um i know my back
hurts my knees hurt but i can't do any
feeling
this is what i'm talking about bill of
somebody who's looking to the future and
saying
i'm never too young to go learn
something new i'm never too young to go
call my local community college class i
got the courage
to do something different to do
something hard to change my mind
to do both and bill i want to tell you
you're a hero without a cape on
and i'm grateful that you called here
you're gonna help
people so much get over that hump that i
can't it's too i'm too old it's too late
that's right
all that is bullcrap you can you just
gotta decide
i'm gonna go suck it up and i'm gonna go
get a certificate i'm gonna go like ken
said i'm gonna go sit down and talk to
somebody
and bill i'd hug you if you were here
i'm so grateful that you called man yeah
you're not too old it's not too late the
reason that people aren't sure if they
can john is because they don't know how
right when we figure out the how and i
mean that when i say
we've all done a term paper in high
school or college but it's different
even the how though because it's
it's bill's got a it could easily be i
don't
i i'm going to feel uncomfortable
sitting in a class college class that's
like a 19 year old
that's true yep you are yeah yeah you're
right you have once you are confronted
with the how you still have to do it
gotta go do it there's no question about
it but i'm telling you one of the
biggest
obstacles for folks is they they
they have this idea that i'm too old i
can't do it it's gonna be too expensive
it's going to take too long
and they're filling in the answers
themselves they don't have the real
answers
and that's what we're imagining a worst
case scenario
or an embarrassment or a failure and
then they reverse engineered it right
now and they just stay put that's why i
love the clarify and verify
just go sit with somebody who's doing
that work yeah and
answer the questions that you don't have
answers to
and all of a sudden it's not so
difficult i mean that's why i wrote the
book the proximity principle that's how
i got into broadcasting starting at 33
with no degree and no connections
i got around the people that were doing
it and i got in places where the work
was happening
i kept showing up and doing it and then
opportunities presented themselves let's
not overthink this is the point folks
and have the courage and go do it yeah
just step out
it is going to be uncomfortable i
promise you all right hey john thanks as
always for hanging out love being with
you i want to thank our producer james
child
i want to help i want to thank our
associate producer at call screen kelly
daniel but most of all
you america thank you for listening this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head to the ramsay show.com thanks
for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
this is the
the ramsay show the ramsay show it's the
ramsay show i almost said the dave
ramsey show for the first time it is the
ramsay show it's just the ramsey
thank you john we are broadcasting from
the dollar car riddle studio
and this is in fact the ramsay show it's
where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
and your money i'm ken coleman
who almost said it wrong and then just
owned it right on the air and
everybody's like why did why did you do
this because i had to stop the brain
it just happens when you go that's not
the way you're supposed to do it
and then you do it john delodie is with
me he bailed me out on that for
reminding me
what we actually call the show and uh
what's most important is
is that we can actually answer your
questions even just even with the
the the brain blips that happen from
time to time which is live broadcasting
it you know it's just kind of like what
what what what what
you got to say it the right way you know
if i've got a work or relationship or
money question
my confidence is brimming right now
it's so true these two guys here's the
lesson here's the lesson
oh here's the lesson when when you
have that happen to you you go on you
move on you have to step right into it
stop call it out move on
yeah yeah it's not the end of the world
you know write that book yeah you know
the show business you know you keep
going you watch these american idol
shows and the kid forgets the lyrics
and it's in the moment it's it's like
death to them and it's like that happens
to everybody and
you just keep rolling regardless of it
but you gotta acknowledge it and then
move on
yeah absolutely triple eight eight two
five five two two five so we're gonna
take your questions on money we'll take
it on work
we will take it on relationships and uh
between the two of us we're gonna get an
entire complete sentence out that will
answer
most if not all of your questions yeah
all the time yeah it's just every once
in a while you're gonna have that blip
hey david joins us now in traverse city
michigan david how can we help
yes i'm here david go ahead brother on
the line how can we help
my question is my wife and i we sold our
house and we have to build another one
and just wondering if we should see a
banker and get a loan
we're going to try to do it debt-free
and we may be 40 to 50 000
short so you just said two conflicting
things
so you sold your house you have a pile
of cash here y'all just renting right
now
yes okay and so you're gonna build a
dream home or a fancy home
the traverse city is a beautiful
beautiful place you got a lot you're
going to build on
yes already have that that's already
paid for and we are
completely debt-free all right no car
payments no credit
cards my business is completely debt
free muscle
excellent so you want to build this debt
free you're going to build this debt
free
but you're going to be 50 000 short and
you may need to get a mortgage
help me with that possibly will be short
dependent on how long it takes us to
build it
walk me through that math well
for the first five years i built my
company up not taking anything
and now i can start reaping the rewards
from that
and the way house the way lumber prices
are and materials
we don't know what that's going to end
up being in six or seven months when
we're almost done with the house
so you think you're going to have a 50
000 overage just in material cost alone
possibly yes okay but how you you're a
guy that's clearly analyzed this
i mean what are the chances of that
happening do you feel like that's a
greater than 50 percent chance
or how are you how are you running those
numbers in that analysis to be able to
go
this could happen what are the variables
well it depends on if it takes us six
months or nine months if it takes us
nine months
i could see us not own anything on it
but if it takes us six months
and my wife has pressured me to go talk
to a banker
and i don't want to do it because i want
to completely debt free the way dave
ramsey wants you to do it
well what can you control doing in nine
months
yes well i i feel like that's what we
need to be doing right
well yeah i i i agree but i'm just
saying is it
wise for me should i think about
getting a loan or should i just say to
forget it and just do it
here's the thing how much how much how
much you sell your other house for
uh we sold it for 324. so you have 324
thousand dollars in cash and then you're
in your checking account
for all intents we have we have
no we have like 240 right now so you got
240
000 and so you're going to build a 250
to 300
000 house right um
no like a 375 000 health because i've
never taken anything out of my company
and now i'm starting to take what i
should take out of the company
okay so let me just make this pretty
simple
if you're going to put down 90
down on a house i got no problem with
you taking out a loan for that last
little bit
if you have worked like you have to
build up a business
and saved your money paid off your house
now you've sold your house
man what's three more months right
that's what i'm thinking yeah that's
why three more it sounds like this is a
much more of a marriage issue than it is
a math problem well it's it's
not really a marriage issue she just
wants me to
make sure that if we are short that we
can get
if we need to the extra 40 000 or 50 and
what we
what should we do should we get a heloc
loan or just get a personal loan
or finance the house if we if we have to
yeah yeah it's a marriage issue in that
what john's saying is your wife wants
you to do something that you don't want
to do
and i think you told me you don't think
you have to do it so don't do it
if you're calling us to say we agree
with your wife we don't
yeah i'm not doing that yeah and i'm
just looking for sound advice
yeah yeah i just i wouldn't i mean you
can as john said but you don't have to
here's here's the the big picture here
david is is um
either way you're going to be okay yeah
either way you're going to be fine
you're just going to go get out
a a mortgage loan that's going to be for
that gap
right you're going to say hey we're
going to put 90 down on this house or 95
down in this house
we're going to go get the loan that's
going to cover that gap
my concern with going to get a 50 000
pot as a quote unquote just in case is
that's how extra bathrooms get added on
that's how extra shops get added on in
the back
and suddenly you end up buying bigger
better
well let's go we got 50 000 here let's
go ahead and the mortgage
payment's only going to be x and what
you end up going way over than what you
wanted to do
so i'd rather see you guys scale this
budget down get somebody to lock it in
there
and go buy it or just be okay saying
we're gonna put 375 thousand dollars
down on this house
325 thousand dollars we're gonna we're
gonna finance the last 50 grand
of it i don't think that's the smart way
but you're not going to hurt anybody
because you're going to pay it off
really quick then you're going to be
done with it
it sounds like you're overthinking it by
um
a hundred degrees and i get the
overthinking because of the psychology
of what you have gone through the pain
you've gone through to get debt free
and it's like why did we do all that
work just to turn right back around
and then take out a loan that's right
like fifty thousand dollars right so
that's why that's why ken and i are both
telling you
man if you're talking three months dude
don't do it feel like three months don't
do it yeah
if you sold your house you put your
house in the market and you were hoping
it's gonna sit for a year and it's sold
overnight
and now your wife is saying hey i don't
want to be renting for a year
you're not gonna you're not gonna hurt
anybody you're not gonna ruin anything
by taking out three months
worth of of a note yeah i just follow
your heart on this i mean i think it's
very obvious anybody listening that you
know you don't want to do that
and appreciate the call but i i'd wait
the extra months but you know
that's what i would do i'd wait the
extra three months we'd have five i'm
gonna feel much better about it and i
think that's what this whole call is
about is the feelings around
i've got these options here what do i do
so really appreciate the call and
congratulations on the sacrifice and
saving
to put yourself in that situation you
are in great shape
all right don't move more of your calls
coming around the corner this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony we're taking your calls triple a
[Music]
825-52258-825-5225
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal remember rules and
restrictions
apply today's question john comes from
annie in indiana
my husband's dream job is to be a
fireman growing up his parents
repeatedly told him he won't make it
and not to try he recently passed two
national tests
but still has the dallas and fears that
he won't make it he doesn't want to hear
his parents say
i told you so what can i do to boost his
confidence so he can pass his next two
tests oh way to go mom and dad
congratulations okay
many times i've heard this on the ken
coleman show where somebody's like i
didn't pursue because mom and dad told
me it's a bad idea
wait a minute mom and dad so what can
you do tell him to do it but john you're
gonna go deeper here
break that down i don't even parents you
do not protect or help your kids
by making them afraid of themselves or
the world
it doesn't help to look at your child
and say you can try you're probably
gonna fail
what is that what does that accomplish
that's a parent hedging their own bets
against their kids future potential let
me say yeah that's absolutely right i'll
just say it this way
uh you are projecting your own fear onto
your kid
your insecurity yes that if they don't
turn out the way that you want them to
turn out that everybody's gonna say
oh margaret and john were bad parents or
they're they they legitimately don't
want my kid their kid to fail because
failure hurts yes their kid from all
hurts will give them a perfect child
nope you'll give them a
non-resilient weak scared broken kid
that's right
struggle makes your kids strong failure
makes your kids strong
that's where you rise out of the ash
like a phoenix
way to go mom and dad way to go yeah so
annie
just like ken said he is doing it
they wouldn't if the the fire department
would have picked him up if he didn't
pass his physicals
the fire department would have picked
him up if he couldn't pass his test
which he has
and here's the thing his parents don't
get a vote yep
right yep i'll add one more thing if he
doesn't pursue this i tell him
you're going to resent your parents
until they die
he is in it he's on it yep go get it yep
you got to do it don't look back love
that
moms and dads when your kid comes to you
with a crazy idea
you can sit down and say hey talk to me
about that
let's go talk to someone at our at my
work that does that job
i want to hear more about this oh let's
read a book together and talk about it
really you want to try that you want to
be a fireman you can't even jog
let's run a 5k together do something
that's going to bring your relationship
together and i'm getting fired up but
i'm sorry
this isn't his fault i can't stand
parents who squash their kids out of
their own fears
yeah now my kid comes and says i'm going
to drop out of high school
and become a dance star
that's not a good idea as your parent
you need to finish high school right
and especially if i've seen you dancing
it's not happening
but there's a difference between saying
hey i'll take dance with you
and saying you're gonna fail you're
never gonna make it yeah what what
you know what i'm saying yeah of course
there's a way to coach your kids
through bad ideas other than just
smashing them but i can tell you this
being a fireman's not a bad idea
so let's relax a little bit yeah you're
going to fail you're going to fail
yeah look hey to annie's husband if your
parents do say i told you so
just let it roll off doesn't matter and
doing this just so you can show them is
gonna that's gotta that's gonna exhaust
you too don't do that do it because you
love being a fireman
you wanna help people good for you yep
absolutely
good advice there triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
evansville indiana and that's where
wade joins us wade how can we help
yes sir i got a question for you okay
i'm a cnc machinist primarily meal
operations here in
my local city uh
long story short i lost a pretty high
paying job due to cove with last march
but i was lucky enough to land another
job in a cnc shop
and uh i'm i lacking experience in lathe
operations and during the interview they
told me that
lathe operations or me getting
experience in late operations was a very
very good possibility but here i am
almost a year later and
i've asked and they've not they've not
even acknowledged
and i was just wondering how to approach
the uh
the bosses about getting that experience
sure when was the last time you asked
and uh there was no acknowledgement i'd
love to know what the timeline looks
like
uh asked about probably two months ago
and did you ask it in in casual
conversation was it in an actual meeting
or did you
ask in the form of maybe an email say
hey i'd like to meet about it and
nothing has been
reciprocated i talked to
my supervisor about it and he said i'll
get you on one
when i can and i'm you know i'm pretty
good at meal operations i've been doing
it for eight years
so okay well i think you should follow
up because because the
the face-to-face conversation was i'm
gonna get you on when i can
and i think you follow up and go hey
last time we met you said you'd get me
on when you can
and i'm really grateful for that i'm
really excited about it just checking
back in just checking in to see
if there's anything that i can do to
help the timeline uh
and i'm assuming it's not and then and
then what are you looking at
maybe ask for a little bit more detail
as to
what determines when he can hey so
let me ask you this wade let's say he
comes to you and says hey
we thought it was going to happen it's
not going to um we need you where you
are that's that's where we see for the
next two to three to five years
is where we're gonna need you um does
that change your
desire to keep working there oh
absolutely i've actually had an
interview
and uh i had to that's where i had it i
had to tell
i had to tell them that i didn't have
lathe experience
and i'm pretty sure i'm not going to get
the job and it's a higher paying job
okay so it may be something that you ask
hey can i go practice the lathe on a
saturday can i come up here on a sunday
and use it i just want to get some
skills and
um i'm willing to come stay after hours
to learn how to do this
um but how can you work around and get
that experience and it may be that your
boss knows that once you get that
experience you're gonna be out the door
right so
there's a hundred different reasons yep
that's right but i'm i'm glad i was
going to ask you what your
or what statement was and you answered
it for me you're already putting your
application
out there you're already trying to find
other places that's right and and listen
this is the indicator
yeah because you've been told yes once
i'm going to try if they keep kicking
the can down the road
it never feels good yeah but the good
news of that
is it's the sign yeah and it's time to
go don't let
that can kicking don't invent stories
and plant them into your boss's head
don't invent stories and plant
it just be a person of gratitude be
gracious and then go find another job
right i mean that's what you can do you
can get angry and bitter and they won't
let
cool they they they spoke and they said
what it's going to be and i'm going to
make another decision for me and my
family yeah right
and there is something about that though
the psychology of it you gotta you gotta
own it it's okay to go man this feels
like rejection
and it feels personal sometimes it is
because we know a lot about healthy
leadership versus unhealthy leadership
but other times it's not personal
right it really isn't there's there's
it's called fundamental attribution
error when i get into somebody else's
head
and determine why they did what they did
oh right we do that with
voters all the time politicians oh he
didn't put me on the lathe
because he knows i'm better than him
right and he's just trying to keep me
down
i see it and then when you think that
you start seeing it everywhere all the
evidence appears
yeah he doesn't open the door for you
and you're like exactly and that guy
didn't open the door for you because
he's got to go to the bathroom
he's not thinking about you right right
and so i want we do with our spouses we
do with our friends
get out of other people's heads right
just look at the data before you
he said hey we're going to try it's been
six months it's not happening yeah
assume he tried and it's not gonna work
then i'm gonna go take my
my my skill set elsewhere and here's why
what you said john is powerful because
we make it about us a hundred percent
but it doesn't matter
whether it's about us or not it's still
we need to move on because i'm looking
at regardless
that's right yeah and if you go let them
know hey i'm moving on because i want to
do lathe work and i've got the
experience and so i appreciate you guys
help then you can you can leave your
heart
you're going to sleep at night your your
heart rate is going to be lower
your life you're going to be healthier
just going about your day man that's it
right yeah yeah just know this is your
sign there's a
there's some country comedian or
somebody that's got a whole uh here's
your sign yeah
here's your side bill bill yeah
that's kind of the deal there's your
sign that's right and and we don't like
those signs
no we don't oh we get so
look it's not personal even if it is
personal it doesn't matter because
you're moving on
moving on anyway yeah it's tough i get
to decide that guy cuts me off on the
highway i get to decide
is he on the way to the er that's good
or is he just doing it to be me
right all right please decide to stay
with us more coming up here on the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are taking your phone calls
aaa 825-5225 and ken i got some big news
our famous
ten dollar sale is here oh boy now you
can learn how to make
faster and real progress with your money
your job
your mental health when you check out
our famous ten dollar sale
save up to sixty percent on over forty
best-selling books and budgeting tools
like the total money makeover
redefining anxiety proximity principle
all of them plus
they make for great gifts for graduates
for people changing jobs moving anything
you can think of they make great gifts
shop our 10 sale at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
and that's not all we got a gift for you
too
you can also enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway
we're giving away 500 cash every week
and a grand prize of 5
000 cash enter daily for extra chances
to win no purchase necessary you got to
be 18
to do this text cash to 33789 to enter
our giveaway
that's cash to 33789
all right good stuff there the phone
number to jump in triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'd love to hear
from you let's go to ann arbor michigan
where kelly is on the line kelly how can
we help
hi um i'm calling today because
um i've been past baby step three but i
feel like i keep on
spending baby step three on emergencies
like for example our windows wouldn't
shut in the winter in michigan
and so we had to buy new windows and
then we built up baby steps three and
then our fridge died
and now we're back up and we're
investing and we're putting money
towards our kids college
but we need to get a new car because our
car is dying and we also
are going to be having more kids soon
and we need more space
and so i don't know if i'm supposed to
be using like all of baby step three to
help
purchase that vehicle or if it's okay to
take a small loan or
or do i even stop like investing in
college and investing in our investments
in order to purchase a car okay well
let's address the one thing we're not
going to do and that's get a loan
we don't want you to get a loan for the
car because you've got you've got
somewhere with all here you know what to
do and how to do it
um how how much are you in a deficit
with your uh
your uh emergency fund right now
right now we have our emergency so it is
back to full about
yeah but then like i said we're falling
like we have this purchase we have to
make again
you know right how much how much do you
want to purchase the car for
we were hoping to get a minivan
that was newer um and most of those are
more than like nine
grand and that's about how much we have
in our emergency fund is nine grand
and so we're just trying to figure out
should we use all of the emergency fund
um because we're planning on like having
a baby in about
10 months you know and so well the
emergency
fund the emergency fund is for an
emergency what's your current car that
you're saying
you're kind of predicting it's death but
we don't really know if that's true is
that correct tell us how bad this
current car is that you're trying to
replace
so right now i need some work done the
ac doesn't work
um the struts are gone um they said
there was going to be at least like a
grand like 800 a grand to get it
working again like not working again but
running safely
and our cars worth about two grand so
it's kind of like
getting like put another grand into it
or sell it for two grand you know
we don't really know what to do like
should we keep going with this car
it only eats like really five people
comfortably but with like
a baby carrier that's not that
comfortable so we drove around my kid
my wife drove our son and i drove to in
a corolla for several years and i'm a
big guy
we made it work and i know that's not
what any new mom wants to hear
i know that's not what you want to have
this big fancy
i get that um but that one thousand
dollars against a two thousand dollar
car
it feels like a quote-unquote bad
investment we're throwing bad money away
but when that instead of that one
thousand dollar expense
if you turn around and loop that into a
17 000 car loan
you've had a net negative right and i
know it's frustrating
here's what i'm going to do if i'm your
husband um i'm going to work
berserker for 10 months yep part of i'm
going to put all that nervous new dad
energy
into extra jobs running around like
bananas i'm going to drive
for uber i'm going to deliver pizzas i'm
doing whatever i got to do
and i'm going to make it a 10-month goal
that i can
add that money into whatever money y'all
have saved for a new car so that i can
get a van
and if you don't if you end up having to
buy a five or ten thousand dollar car
it's not going to be the end of the
world yeah it's just not i agree
that's the other option kelly is does it
have to be a nine thousand dollar
minivan you know
i but if for me i'd spend the thousand
dollars on on on fixing
the current car you guys have
replenished your emergency fund multiple
times
so you've got a success track record
here you can save money in your house
and
here's what i want to acknowledge it's
so frustrating oh yeah
oh it's a beating yeah but you guys
could save up the nine grand
what can you do what can you sell you
know to come up with the nine grand
after you fix the current car for for a
thousand right and you replace that
money in the emergency fund and you come
up to nine grand you get the thing and
the baby's happy and the baby never even
knew
but here's one thing you've proven
yourself and i hate to twist your words
on you but are you ready
here's what you've proven to yourself
things are gonna happen
you're gonna need that emergency fund
and so by
by buying windows and then getting the
emergency fund back up fixing the next
thing getting emergency fund back
up it's annoying and frustrating but the
emergency fund is working
and to then take it to buy a car with it
you know what's gonna happen next
your heater's gonna quit right some your
roof's gonna have a hole in it and now
you're gonna have to go take out a big
loan and now you're
back down the hill yeah right so hang
hang
in there that's right hang in there
you've proven to yourself did i use any
of it
i wouldn't use any of the emergency
funds or no if you have a new baby on
the way i want that emergency fund
between
four and five and six months so any
money on top of that should go into a
separate account
that is going to be your car purchase
fund yeah the only emergency but the
answer is no you don't use your
emergency fund to buy a car
you use your emergency fund to fix the
current car for a thousand bucks
right and then you save that money and
you replenish it and i know it's so fr
you you were hoping we were going to say
hey it's your first baby go get that van
yeah go get that van i i know the
frustration of putting money into an
older car oh i do too
i mean you want to talk about it's
always not fun to use the emergency fund
but when you're using it on an older car
you're like you've got to be kidding me
yes
yes but i have to remind myself big
picture that's that is what you always
come back to
and i don't want my kid if i can if i
can help it you guys have worked too
hard to get out of debt
don't bring a brand new baby into that
stress right you guys have just worked
too hard
you've worked too hard yeah and she's
got it right and
one of the things we we mentioned
briefly but this is something i've
learned
because i'm i'm looking at you know
cheap cars and i i mean cheap in all
caps yes me too because i got a 15 year
old that's gonna be 16 in november
you know what i mean and i'm going yes
i mean if i could find a fred flintstone
car for him yes
that's what i would give him because you
know if he can erect that you know you
know i don't want the bad things to
happen but the point is right
it is what it is the nine thousand
dollars that's pretty nice
do you know how many nice vehicles i
mean like not garbage
absolutely highly functional vehicles
are in the five to seven
range over the internet that's right
and one of the funniest slash
i've got pride in the wrong places okay
so yeah hear me say that
but when i bought this sixteen thousand
dollar truck off a used lot
yes i don't know how old it is my son
climbed into it and he looked around and
he looked at me
and said dad are we rich
and because of how bad my other car had
been i get it and i looked at her and
said
yes son you know what i mean i was like
you've got no idea
but he really was like what's up now and
it was an 06
i mean it was something well it was
probably the new car smell spray it
i did i i waxed it with a new car and
again the
point is not to drive crummy cars right
dave and i've had this conversation over
and over and over
um it's not that's not the point the
point is to drive cars within your
overall budget that's right
yeah and it's not fun it's the worst and
the worst is is we we live in a world
where everybody's driving around a car
that they can't even afford yes and you
will and you're looking at them and
you're going man
that car looks nice i'd like to drive
that then i don't have any debt
i've got a good job and this is a car
i'm driving oh yeah
not that i didn't think that on the way
to work this morning right right but
it's like right
nope i'm gonna keep doing it right i'm
gonna keep doing it right i'm gonna have
that magic word and have patience yeah
and your baby's going to love you anyway
whether it's in a corolla or one of them
those brand new those new plymouth
minivans
oh it's crazy but that babies just need
to be in the car seat that's right
you know so you got this you guys kelly
have done a great job
so dealing with life coming at you keep
doing it the way you've been doing it
don't get distracted
you got this and congratulations yes on
the baby
all right don't move more ramsay show
coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john deloney thrilled to have you with
us triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
today's scripture of the day colossians
4
6 let your conversation be always full
of grace
seasoned with salt so that you may know
how to answer
everyone and our quote today comes from
john maxwell
a leader is great not because of his or
her power
but because of his or her ability to
empower
others triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to jump in
let's go to indianapolis indiana where
phil
joins us phil how can we help
hey guys uh thanks for taking my call
it's great to speak with you
um my wife and i are considering making
a fairly large purchase
and i wanted to just basically get a
third opinion
from you guys based on where we are in
the baby steps
okay where are you in the baby steps
well um we are i believe
at a baby step six
um we are debt-free with the exception
of our house okay
we have a fairly uh over-funded
emergency and fund at this point
honestly
uh due to some extenuating circumstances
but uh
we do have about 175 000 in an emergency
fund
what's the circumstances um
i was involved in an accident okay that
uh resulted in a settlement that um
padded that a little bit and just uh
basically gone
unallocated up to this point hanging out
there okay tell us tell us how much
overage you have so we know what that
number is
um six months of expenses for us
probably looks somewhere in the
neighborhood of about
uh forty thousand dollars so it's
way way over right yes sir okay
all right so you got a 130 grand just
just parked there yeah
how much you got left on your mortgage
man it's a blessing
but at the same time it's a little bit
of overwhelming but yeah that's right
how much you get left on your mortgage
um so our mortgage is the balance is
about
250. okay and we are contributing a
little extra to that
okay so what's your question well uh
basically the the purchase that we're
looking to make
it is uh a luxury purchase if you will
my wife and i have
kind of dreamed for a long time of
owning an rv um we have two young
children
and uh the price tag on that is around
thirty thousand dollars
and um like i said at the outset
kind of just looking for a green light
if you will
um because you know my wife and i we
just i'm the budget
the nerd the conservative and my wife is
more of the free spirit and i guess it's
just kind of uh
dude dude uh how about not a green light
how about the old green flag of the
nascar race i'm waving my arm
i mean 30 000 to buy an rv and you still
have
overages you would like to call 100
grand 100 grand extra in your emergency
fund that you could put on that house
they say yeah i'm good probably i'm good
with that yeah there's probably a lot of
people rolling their eyes that
worry about all those people yeah they
don't get a vote yeah if you
if you go buy that 30 000 rv today with
cash
and that doesn't mean you have to then
buy a 70 000 truck to pull it right
you've got all that down
and you go take that other 100 grand and
tomorrow morning or monday morning you
go
put that against your mortgage to where
your mortgage only 150 grand on the left
then man i say high five and stop by
nashville and see us on your way on your
first trip yeah come take a picture in
front of the building
listen man i've been down to see you
guys once before but i'd love to come
back
bring the rv john and i'll come in and
have a cookie i will not but
really no i probably would yeah of
course you i love rvs
yeah i think this is great man
congratulations you guys have done the
hard work
uh keep walking this thing out i mean
that you know
you guys yes do this celebrate and you
know this
once you have 150 grand left on your
house man it's pretty easy to
make eye contact with your wife decide
you're going to go gazelle intense for
just a short season and knock that
sucker out too
right yeah that's the dream that's
awesome
phil way to go you guys deserve this you
have the cash this is not a silly
crazy vain whatever word that you've
been putting in your head this is okay
yeah you got a hundred thousand extra
dollars good for you yeah
let's go to chicago next where jason
joins us jason how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
i am
uh i'm currently debt-free outside of my
mortgage
and in about two months i will
have enough stock uh non-retirement
stocks saved up
uh that i can sell and actually pay off
my mortgage
um which in my head sounds like a great
idea to get out from under this and so
i'm just calling to
get some advice so are these just single
stocks floating out there that you've
just purchased over time
yeah basically uh you know through my
own company
i get to uh purchase the company i work
for fantastic
and then you but you have an external
401 or external retirement program
that's separate than this
yes and i'm maxing that out uh and i max
it out every single year
okay actually i get money back every
year good for you terrible you know you
said something
you said something interesting jason and
i could be reading into this but you
said in my head
sounds like the right thing to do and
i'm wondering is there somebody else
that has a different voice in their head
that's involved in this or
is that just the way you said it no no
my wife is completely on board as well
and okay good both
um you know we've been rambling fans and
and have gotten
you know this far um you know it's still
i owe
270 on my house and literally
i'll have the stock to do that
and then be debt-free and then the idea
would be to kind of start building that
back up again but
you know i don't know how much is the
house worth
right now uh probably 690.
dude what are the what are the taxes
against those stocks
stock sale um i
you know i would have to i would have to
run the numbers on it um
that's something david left off of his
head yeah that's right that's a good
point because i think i think
we were assuming i know i incorrectly
assumed that you had run the math on if
you're going to cash those stocks out
you got to know what your tax hit is on
that so
if you're but yeah single stock selling
brother don't touch your retirement yeah
but sell the single stocks be debt free
in your house and then come down here
nashville
and scream it as loud as you can here on
the debt free stage brother yeah
absolutely love it yeah congratulations
man that's fantastic i mean you just
think about that you know
because you got some people i know are
going oh that stock obviously this guy's
done you know he's done pretty well
there
but wait a second there's no guarantee
those stocks are going to hold that
especially internal circulating
companies stocks right my mom worked for
this little company
for several years called enron yes oh
yeah and she worked for another little
company called deloitte and twos
they loved the internal circulation boy
is that the truth
you know enron was as about as sure a
thing as there was it was the surest
and you want to talk about it didn't
exist quick yeah it just evaporated
didn't exist
right and so but the difference is
they're debt free have a nearly 700
000 house yeah paid for it and more
importantly
i want everybody here saying you're not
cashing out retirement no
but we're not talking about people we're
not getting into all the
cash enough for ones and i i've been
guilty of that of looking at it and
saying
man i'd love to have that cash i want to
go ahead and i think this is the top of
the market or whatever not since i
thought i'd sure
and um we're not what we're saying but
yeah you got these floating stocks out
there
yeah cash them out get rid of them pay
your house off and we're going to be
good to go
so ken um real quick you've got a big
event coming up
tell us about it yeah the get hired
event is uh april the 27th
eight eastern seven central it's gonna
be a live stream event so you can get it
anywhere you've got an internet
connection
and a device tickets start at just
twenty dollars you can text the word
hired at three three seven eight nine
and what we're gonna do in that night
is we're gonna break down the three
key things you've got to do to beat the
competition because
at the end of the day with the way that
artificial intelligence
is being used when you submit a resume
yeah there's things you've got to do on
the resume
just to get noticed because they're
doing keyword search and things like
that
and then you've got to go the human
route which is what i teach
which is always going to be artificial
intelligence john because if i got a
connection
it's over and somebody's willing to walk
my resume in even though i had to submit
it online they went hey john let me tell
you about this guy i know
i think you ought to consider him i've
known him this long that's the game
changer it is
and every job of my life absolutely true
so we're going to go into that kind of
detail it's going to be a lot of fun
uh again you can get your tickets
starting at just twenty dollars text the
word hired
to three three seven and you've got some
cool stuff planned for this this is
not just going to be oh hey ken coleman
like in one of those really short faces
in front of a zoom call you've got a
whole bunch of stuff going on right yeah
it's gonna be a lot of fun we're gonna
do some live q a so you hear real
people's questions as we begin to walk
through what they're dealing with and
how they overcome it so it's gonna be a
lot of fun thanks for bringing that up
dr john delay make sure you all check
out the dr john de leni show on the
ramsey
solutions network it's a great great
podcast also on youtube
blowing up hey john thanks for hanging
with me you too man always fun i want to
thank our producer
james childs and our associate producer
and call screener kelly daniel
and you america thank you for listening
this has been the ramsay show
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you